[Music]
in the prior segment chris sims was
talking to him for read about deandre
swift being at number five
on the chris sims top five running back
prospects that defies and contradicts
the opinions of many there's the full
list
top five as ranked by chris sims and
number one clyde edwards hillaire from
lsu a bit of a stunner chris not one of
the guys regarded as being
the top running backs in this year's
draft why did you pick him
well i just look at him and go wow i
mean i'm watching mark ingram or ray
rice but with better quickness if that
makes any sense as a football player
mike i mean he has that type of power
but then in the open field i mean he's
electric mike he can break ankles he can
re-accelerate in three steps he's got
pretty good long speed don't be fooled
by the four six forty because i could
show you a lot of runs in the sec where
he's running away from a lot of people
who are running four four and four five
so that's one of those times i don't pay
attention to that but mike you know to
be able to be an in between the tackles
runner and then be an unbelievable
third down route running type running
back out of the backfield i mean he's a
special route runner let alone he's not
you're not able to tackle him in space i
mean the first guy always misses and
then the second guy if you're still in
space is going to miss you as well i i
would think edward's hilaire mike
just after breaking them down
he has a chance to be a first round
running back there's no doubt and i
think when you know i i i feel very
confident about this he fits everything
any offense would want to do let alone
mike you know yes he'll get what's there
to be had but he'll get a lot more than
what's there to be had a lot of the
times because of some of his great
physical traits
would he be the only guy that you would
put that first round grade on for this
year i think jonathan taylor could be in
that conversation you know again when
you start talking about mike a guy
that's
wow
227 228 pounds can run you over in the
hall moves the pile forward every time i
watch him and i mean when you know
there's two yards right mike and the
hole is filled with two linebackers he
gets four yards he always falls forward
and keeps things moving that way let
alone again this is why i say these two
guys are first-round talents he's got
some elite traits yes the physical the
pat you know the physicality and the
power i talked about but this is the
fastest guy of the group i mean it
doesn't matter really what game you turn
on he can turn the corner and run for 70
yard touchdowns or split the middle of
the ohio state defense and run for an 80
you know a 50 yard touchdown he has game
breaking type speed and that's special
you just don't see a whole lot of guys
coming around the nfl very often who
were 228 pound running backs and as
thick and powerful as he is then also be
able to run 439 so yes i look at those
two guys as clearly my top two running
backs and two guys that i do think have
the talent uh to to justify a first
round pick
taylor has a very electric engaging
personality i was able to him at the
scouting combine before the world turned
upside down but he's got a lot of wear
and tear he's got a lot of carries a lot
of yards and you know some people look
at a guy's career as the full college
pro experience combined and there's only
so many touches there's only so many
yards before the tread comes off the
tires and taylor has put in a lot of
work chris at the college level are you
concerned about that well yeah i am to a
degree of course i mean you have to take
that into account now he's built like a
brick house you know so that's one thing
like you saw him in person you could
he's one of those guys where like you go
man if i stuck a knife into his arm i'm
not sure it would go in the knife might
bend you know so he was built and met
meant to play this position in the nfl
you know and there's been also listen
there's been other plenty of running
backs who have been bell cows hey mark
ingram's still going derrick henry still
going so i'm not worried from that
standpoint but here's the big point mike
to me
we got to stop thinking of like oh we're
drafting a running back and he's going
to be our guy for the next eight years
no that's just not the way it is
drafting a running back you gotta look
at it like hey i got a four five maybe
five year window
things are probably gonna break down or
fall off at the end of this rookie
contract and if they don't it's just
icing on the cake and oh great man we
got lucky and got a guy that we can give
a second contract to but i think really
when you're doing the running back
position this day and age right now you
almost have to be expecting i'm really
only gonna have this guy four or five
years and i'm probably gonna have to
move on or draft somebody else once
again too
yeah but actually in this day and age
the reality is the player has a great
four or five years so great that you
have to sign him to the second contract
and then when you do
it starts to fall apart that's the
concern and the players are pushing for
the deals earlier like ezekiel elliott
last year like christian mccaffrey will
this year like dalvin cook may in
minnesota but
it feels like you get the best out of
these guys year one year two year three
and then it starts to plateau or dip and
the problem is when you have that
workhorse tailback that's why i think
it's great to have two or three guys
when you have one guy who becomes that
superstar who is generating a ton of
yardage a bunch of touchdowns for the
fantasy football crowd and everybody
buys his jersey and he's everyone's
favorite player
then you have to pay him it makes it so
much harder to rip that band-aid off and
let him leave look at what the steelers
went through with le'veon bell and they
were lucky that bell wasn't more
identified as the star of the team
because they had antonio brown they had
ben roethlisberger and that's a team
that relies so heavily on defense but
for so many teams that running back
becomes bigger than the franchise
what do you do
you pay him and then you regret it chris
no i mean you're right and i think
that's one reason one more reason to
have you know a little bit of a running
back to my committee you can make a guy
that's maybe your focal point running
back superstar guy like you're talking
about maybe last a little longer to
where he can get into that second
contract and still have some value there
but you know and the big thing to me
mike is yeah i mean listen this is just
a harsh reality you're right and it's a
tough situation for teams and certainly
they're gonna have to be careful i wish
they could find a way
to pay these guys
better
in their first four to five years of
their career where it's like the running
back only counted like 80 of his
contract against the salary cap or
something like that because to what
you're saying it's one horror story
after another you know it's aryan
foster leading the nfl twice and rushing
before he gets paid
i can think of alfred morris with the
redskins and the washington redskins
with kyle shanahan you know on his
rookie contract he was a top five rusher
in the nfl twice but never gets the big
payday because like you're saying by the
time it's year five he's beat to hell
and he's got nothing left and that's
where i really have a soft place in my
heart for this position in the nfl
there was a push last year by a lawyer
in chicago and she was trying to create
a separate bargaining unit for running
backs and there is right merit to that
we went through that discussion last
month with the cba you've got a bunch of
different interests and a bunch of
different levels of contact values of
contract length of career and the
running back has huge value early in his
career and then it diminishes and unless
you are that first-round pick you're not
getting rewarded for what you do early
in your career and you just have to hope
that your team will take care of you
before the wheels start to come off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports